[Music]
foreign hello there you are watching The
Press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the associate
editor of the Daily Mirror Kevin McGuire
and the Daily Mail columnist Sarah Vine
welcome and great to see both of you
from Pages let's kick off with those
shall we uh your attack on small boats
law is wrong Archbishop reads the front
of the Daily Express as the Archbishop
of Canterbury questions the morality of
the government's plan to tackle illegal
migration what's so moral about not
stopping people's Smugglers reads the
front of the Daily Mail as they lead
with the same story
the financial times looks at plans to
stop family members from joining
overseas Masters students at British
universities
Whitehall blob halts repeal of brexit
Lords reads the front of the Daily
Telegraph as they look at government
plans to scrap All European Union laws
the front of the times reporting that
Medics with less training are being sent
into surgeries to boost ranks their
headline NHS plans to send more doctors
into GP surgeries
the hidden toll of long covid that is
the front page of the Daily Mirror they
are reporting two million britons now
have symptoms
and cool Britannia is on the front page
of the Daily Star as they predict white
vests
white vests are the fashion trend of the
summer
Kevin will try out next week or not
anyway a reminder by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen to the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
so let's head to Kevin McGuire and Sarah
Vine and lots of coverage about the
Archbishop of Canterbury speaking out
not least from the mail in the express
Kevin was he right to say a bill that he
disagrees with is a moral and is it
right that Bishops speak out in the
House of Lords as they are Lords
yeah and uh I know I do have a white
vest I just didn't realize it made me
trendy but um
it's always controversial when the
Archbishop can't be or any Bishop
attacks a government it's nothing new I
remember there was a huge Row in the
mid-1980s when Robert runsey was the
Archbishop of Canterbury I think it was
uh 85 faith in the city with Margaret
Thatcher warning massive unemployment
and poverty in cities was written
Britain apart um I think it's a peculiar
system that one we have an established
church church of England the official
religion of a country where most people
aren't uh active uh active Christians in
any way uh and then secondly you have a
House of Lords that they sit in no seats
are reserve for other faiths but if he
is there and he feels strongly I feel
the man who crowned a king on Saturday
in the Abbey a king who has said that
the plan to deport asylums because
refugees migrants to Rwanda is quote
appalling on close because I think he
within the system is entitled to his
view many people will will share what he
what he says because of course it
breaches quite clearly the UN Refugee
convention 1951 that Britain has signed
up but it will almost certainly breach
the European convention on human rights
to bridge which Britain has signed up
the government cannot say it's a legal
migration bill is legal in fact there
was a warning from the uh Home Secretary
that it that it may not be
um and I think this idea that refugees
Asylum sick as anyone who riches Britain
then is automatically said you can't
come here when there are no safe and
legal routes for them to use otherwise
and they would have a valid claim to
stay as most of them do who now cross uh
on those small boats I I do think it is
a moral so under the system yes he has
he has a right to speak out okay A
little contested but I think it's it's
with he's within his rights within the
system I think the system is wrong in
many ways I also think that bill is very
wrong yeah I mean loads of reaction to
this not least from some Tories in the
chamber who are supporting the
government's legislation like former
brexit Chief negotiator and Minister
Lord Frost said he resented accusations
to Illegal migration bill was immoral or
evil one obvious reality he said is that
tense perhaps hundreds of millions of
people could establish an asylum claim
if they could get to this country and
many want to Millions perhaps a stretch
there but who knows
um Arch enemies the front page of the
Metro Sarah Arch enemies the church
leader calling the Rwanda migration Bill
morally unacceptable in the Face-Off
with the Prime Minister where do you
stand on this oh
well I mean I think what's interesting
about the papers because you know talk
about the pay-per-view is is the Divide
yeah it's there's such a strong divide
of a division of opinion on this issue
and basically there are those who agree
with the Archbishop and the king
um I mean the king is not supposed to
comment on things like this but he did
and that in itself was controversial and
those who feel that what the government
is trying to do which is to discourage
people from coming here so that they can
put an end to the criminality then and
and the gangs who are transporting uh
migrants and putting their lives at risk
and that this is the best way they have
the best system they have come up with
they have not they have failed to stop
them thus far and they're hoping that um
the prospect of ending up in Rwanda will
put a lot of people off coming
um I don't think that uh I mean I don't
know if the Archbishop has a better idea
about how to discourage people from
coming to this country via dangerous
fruits but as Kevin says uh there should
be more uh legal routes for people to
come and that is something that I think
is is needs to be addressed
um but what they're trying to do is to
deal with the immediate problem which is
uh you know smuggling roots
okay I'm just looking at the financial
times on a sort of connected story uh
the suggestion that Rishi sunak is ready
to curb students family visas
um ministers are drawing up plans to
stop family members from joining
overseas Masters students at British
universities as rishis United braces
himself for figures showing record net
migration to the UK Kevin just quickly
then
no no absolutely it's the the record was
504 000 according to the Center for
policy studies on May 25th figures will
show that it could be more than 700 000
net migration now students are part of
that there's about 136 000 family uh
members allowed in mainly from India and
Nigeria according to this piece but it's
interesting because the illegal
migration or the illegal illegal
migration bill will basically deal with
people coming on on boats now that's
about 40 000 this is seven hundred
thousand it's almost as if the
government wants us to focus on those
boats to take attention away from the
much bigger number now certainly those
students who who come but they pay for
for Education they uh they stay here for
a while then they they go back it's
actually good it's good for Britain but
I I've always thought it's odd that they
are actually in the migration figures
because they're they're coming here for
a temple period yes well the suggestion
is that students have been one of the
main drivers of the post-pandemic surge
in migration with almost 500 000 student
visa visas issued by the UK authorities
in 2022 and the Ft suggesting that
students especially from Nigeria and
India have become more likely to bring
family with them 135 000 visas granted
to dependents last year that's up from
Sixteen thousands in 2019 so a massive
increase in Independence coming over
watchmate for that one in the meantime
what to do about the bonfire of the
brexit laws has it been abandoned this
is the Daily Telegraph baming the
Whitehall blob halts the repeal of all
these brexit laws but what was the point
of rushing them Sarah
well I don't know I think I think that
you know the government have a lot of
boxes to tick before the next election
don't they I mean that's the thing I
mean their red wall is uh looking
increasingly unsteady and of course
brexit and particularly the reli you
know the the sort of
Britain being tied to EU legislation was
a central a central argument for leaving
the EU for many people who voted leave
so I think they're just trying to get
that
um you know they would like that to be
done
um but it's also part of the wider route
that we've seen in the last couple of
weeks about you know the sort of almost
open Warfare that now seems to be taking
place between the Civil Service and the
current Administration you know uh
they've been trying to get rid of I'm
trying to get rid of as many ministers
as they can it would seem there's this
you know there's there's a real kind of
pushback from uh from the government
against the sort of idea that the Civil
Service trying to basically portray the
Tory government as bullies and you know
aggressors so it's there's a kind of
it's a it's a bit of beef really isn't
it I mean the climb down Telegraph
saying has angered Tory brexiteers the
business secretary announcing she could
only immediately scrap or a form of
about 600 EU laws because of the
situation that she inherited
um isn't it best to go through them
carefully Kevin or or what
God that color's just sensible isn't it
common sense can we perish the thought
look I think brexiteers uh lied to
themselves and lied to the country that
somehow uh leaving the European Union
one would be easy which which it wasn't
two it would be prosperous which it
isn't and three you could somehow just
rip up all these laws and do uh do
whatever you like well a lot of these
laws are rather sensible and they're on
employment on the environment on
consumer rights uh on how we how we live
our lives and you can replace them with
a sticky you know a Union flag on them
and replace them if you like but somehow
can have this massive shredding and they
they thought there were two thousand
four hundred bits of legislation now
they found out there's four thousand
eight hundred I think it's I think it's
unfair to blame Whitehall in transitions
I think what's happened is they they've
just promised something you could never
deliver for a British sunak did it as
well because he wanted to give red meat
to his uh is extremist is you who is
Europe in Reform Group MPS so I get them
on site and can be bad not she's back in
brexit she's the business secretary if
it was if it was sensible or possible
she would do it but she can't but she
has to blame somebody else rather than
saying I can be bad or not but she sued
at everybody else who was saying this
could be done we got it wrong I mean
that that is the reality it is not civil
servants it's not white all and
um they get things wrong
um of course of course they do it's it
doesn't always work well with civil
servers but to just blame him is just
rather convenient
okay let's move on to the picture on the
front page of the financial times uh the
disruption demonstrations protests after
the arrest of uh Imran Khan the ex
Pakistan prime minister on corruption
charges a second day of unrest
um there's a supporter of Imran Khan
flinging a stone at police during these
protests um uh Sarah certainly looking
volatile
I mean very volatile I don't I I'm not
really I think Kevin probably
understands the story better than me
because I'm I'm a bit I don't really
understand what's going on Kevin can you
sort of go through it for us yeah well
well I think I think the the military
the uh the military in Pakistan which is
incredibly powerful and part of the
state they help put that Imran Khan in
power he fell out with them they've now
put somebody else in and they seem to be
wanting to uh make sure he can't have a
comeback because he he's popped he's
popular out of power uh no it's really
frightening in uh Pakistan which is uh
has suffered Coos uh there was a serious
problem with corruption absolutely but
the military has has too much power now
is he is he guilty of corruption or not
Imran Khan um I do not know I do not
know but I can believe that charges are
also trumped up uh in an attempt to fit
him up I'm not saying that is the case
but it's these it's destabilizing
Pakistan again which is a huge a huge
danger both for Pakistan itself uh that
region and the rest of the world this is
a nuclear armed State we should we
should never forget but it's also quite
quite you know important uh in terms of
uh battling uh terrorists as well uh
over the Border in uh Pakistan so we
we've got a you know we've got to hope
that somehow resolves itself and I don't
know what Britain can do but if there's
anything we can then we we've got to try
and do it okay let's do the front page
of the times then Sarah shall we
um the idea that thousands of Hospital
doctors without the highest level of
training as they put it here will be
drafted into GP surgeries under plans to
reduce waiting times and free up
appointments all sort of re-jigging with
the same toys at the moment to try and
make the the system more efficient
possibly
well I think I think it's it's it ties
in with rishi's plan to make pharmacists
um you know do some of the leg work to
you know to be able to prescribe for
minor ailments those sore throats
urinary tract infections things that you
know perhaps you don't need to see your
GP for but which pharmacist can diagnose
and prescribe and what he's trying to do
here is to introduce slightly less
well-qualified GPS they're called SAS
GPS which makes them sound very exciting
and then and they're going to abscale
down your window and come rescue you but
um uh but I mean I'm sure they're
they will be a sort of second tier of GP
I suppose it would work quite well if if
you know you just saw an sas GP for
something very simple and if they
weren't sure if they had doubts they
could then refer you to the senior the
more senior GP it's I mean I think it
sounds like a good idea just getting as
just trying to get the backlog or you
know created partly by covid
um and just by you know massive over
demand just trying to get it moving I
think it's a I think it's a pretty
clever idea myself